it's an experience that you can only
relate to if you've been in it well now
former nickelodeon star jeanette mccurdy
is ready to let us all in on her
experience of being a child actor in her
new memoir i'm glad my mom died and the
now 30 year old is not holding back
saying she felt exploited at the height
of her icarly career don't start with me
ooh someone's extra feisty today
my mom's been chewing on my nerves
jeanette started filming the sitcom when
she was just 14 years old and explains
in her book that her seemingly glamorous
life was a facade
telling the new york times quote my
whole childhood and adolescence were
very exploited it still gives my nervous
system a reaction to say it jeannette
walked away from acting in recent years
her last gig at the studio ended in
2014. in the interim between leaving
nickelodeon i wanted to really focus on
myself and my own life and i think i've
been acting about six years old i'm very
career driven but i really felt that i
needed to find more of a balance in my
life so that i could get more in touch
with my emotions and not find all of my
identity in my career she started
working at just six years old landing
her breakout role as sam puckett on
icarly in 2007
[Music]
the actress says there were instances
where people had the best intentions in
her career but others knew exactly what
they were doing
one memory that sticks with her being
photographed in a bikini at a wardrobe
fitting and encouraged to drink alcohol
by an intimidating figure on set e.t has
reached out to nickelodeon for comment
and we should note e.t and nickelodeon
are both part of the paramount family
when are we going to get a salmon cat
reunion i
i don't know considering the recent
shambles that nickelodeon has been
through when e.t chatted with jeanette
back in 2018 the actress alluded to her
reasons for not reprising her most
famous role and she's been pretty clear
since the show ended i started icarly
when i was 14 i'm ready and eager for
something that's more mature jeanette's
also made it no secret as her book title
suggests that her late mom debra was
directly involved with all the things
she disliked about her hollywood
experience
in the book she claims her mother didn't
speak up and simply told her that's the
price of showbiz success
adding everyone wants what you have
i could never do this show without you
still fans have been holding out for a
cameo from jeanette on the icarly reboot
i mean probably the most successful web
series in history
the character carly very much still
loves sam and always will
um and we all really wanted jeannette to
be a part of the show in real life but
um
she's just doing other things and we're
really happy for
and while that's unlikely to happen
miranda cosgrove still has her tv bffs
back
speaking out in support of her former
co-star and telling the new york times
she was unaware of what jeanette was
going through during the show's original
run
quote you can't imagine that people
around you are having much harder
struggles
miranda adds you don't expect things
like that from the person in the room
who's making everyone laugh i made you a
sandwich
jeanette's book is out august 9th
[Music]
you